what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and the battle to the
death between shoto todoroki and his
villain brother has just reached its
boiling point the entire coming award is
now on fire as shoto's flames clash with
dobby's bluer flames and it looks like
shoto has taken the responsibility of
killing his villain brother upon his own
shoulders this is a massive turning
point in the story and it will set the
stage for the rest of this epic war arc
so let's get into it you guys know how
this works if you like our videos and
you want to see more just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps us with that youtube
algorithm and of course subscribing and
hitting that notification bell is a
completely free but very important way
of directly supporting the channel i
also recently made a video about what a
potential mha time skip would look like
so if that's something you're interested
in definitely check it out after this
video link in the description finally
this video will of course contain boku
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned the
latest chapter focuses on the intense
battle to the death between shoto and
dabi and the complex and dramatic
history of the todoroki family which
looms heavily over the entire chapter we
started off with an explanation of
endeavour's special move flash fire fist
in order to perform this move the user
of a strong fire quirk must raise their
internal temperature and accumulate as
much heat as possible they then release
that heat in extremely powerful bursts
the technique was initially perfected by
a young endeavor and it is believed to
be the strongest fire move and not just
endeavour's strongest move but the
strongest move that any fire-based quark
user can do at least that's how i
interpreted this passage after he
developed this technique endeavour felt
like he had attained the full potential
of his abilities after all he created a
move that literally every other fire
quirk user will want to emulate he was a
pioneer but due to the legacy that he
left for his children the heat from
those flames would one day warp the
future that he had dreamed of it is a
pretty poetic beginning to the chapter
and we are then thrust back into the
blazing inferno of the ongoing battle
between dabi and shoto the heat is now
so intense that the almighty statue in
kamino literally begins to melt as
shoto's fire clashes with dobby's blue
flames dabi looks like he is completely
out of control he looks like a wild
beast consumed by his own hatred and his
own flames and shoto is clearly
concerned about where this battle will
ultimately lead not only is shoto
himself in danger but dabi's massive
flames are quickly becoming a threat to
the entire city shoto also notices that
the rate at which dabi is raising his
internal temperature is just not normal
it's not something that any regular
human should be able to do and this
again seems to back up my theory that
dobby is actually a human nomu hybrid
since we know that he doesn't have a
natural resistance to flames like shoto
and endeavor do he should not be able to
withstand such heat the fact that he can
withstand it and keep functioning tells
me that the procedure which was used to
heal him after that fire on sekoto peak
probably turned him into a human nomu
hybrid and that is why he can still
survive and function even though a
normal human would already be dead by
now even though dabi is completely out
of control shoto vows that he will be
the one to stop him as i said earlier
dabi is not just a danger to shoto if
this continues he will endanger the
entire neighborhood or maybe even the
entire city because his gigantic fire
could begin to spread from building to
building on the other hand dobby
proclaims that he has been preparing for
years for this moment the moment that he
murders shoto in the meantime dabi has
become completely desensitized to pain
and he has been practicing endeavors
special moves including flash fire fist
but because dubby's flames are even
stronger than endeavors his attacks are
even more powerful and also harder to
predict and control we see an example of
this when dobby uses endeavour's attack
hellspider an attack in which endeavour
produces a web of fire that emerges from
his fingers but dubby's health spider is
much bigger and wilder after all when
endeavour uses the attack he is trying
to keep it contained so as not to harm
any innocent bystanders but of course
dobby doesn't care about any of that he
unleashes the attack without any
restraint because he doesn't care who
gets hurt in the process that is exactly
what makes dobby so dangerous not only
are his flames more powerful than
endeavors but he himself is completely
unstable and unhinged and he doesn't
value human life at all endeavour's
sidekicks helped shoto contain dabi's
flames but this attack was only the
beginning as dabi pounces on shoto and
sends him flying with a fiery punch to
the face he rails against shoto for
having the perfect body and the perfect
training environment and perfect
everything but still being a coddled
child who clings to others dabi is
unleashing attack after devastating
attack on shoto who is clearly on the
defensive at this point in the battle
and he looks like he's in serious
trouble dobby calls shoto a puppet but a
puppet who can't even do its job
correctly finally as he hits shoto again
dabi declares that his little brother
will never become a hero dobby then fire
punches shoto straight into a building
and he seems to have expected this
attack to basically end the fight
however dabi is surprised to see that
shoto was able to neutralize the attack
as he emerges from the fiery rubble
shoto says that dabi has a point in some
ways shoto is a loser who took a long
time to figure out exactly who he is and
what he wants to do he went from
despising his father and refusing to use
the fireside of his quirk to having a
slightly more positive relationship with
his father to now seemingly trying to
repair his relationship with his father
and bring his entire family back
together but shoto says that now that he
knows that his older brother toya was
actually observing him from afar rather
than just obsessing over endeavor all
this time he actually feels happy i mean
it's clear that shoto really wishes that
things were different he really wishes
that he didn't have to fight his own
brother to the death but unfortunately
he knows that he has no other choice as
much as he'd love for his brother to
just become a part of the family again
he knows that dobby in his current
mental state will never do this and so
shoto has vowed that he himself will
stop dobby once and for all back when
the heroes were making plans for this
war arc shoto insisted on being the one
tasked with fighting dobby and that is
because he felt that he was best suited
for the job he also developed a new move
specifically for this fight a move that
could be the dobby killer shoto then
explains that yes their household was
hell and their father was insane but at
the end of the day dobby is the one who
willingly chose to walk the path of
murder dobby can't put that decision on
endeavour or anyone else he made that
choice for himself and he will now have
to answer for that decision shoto
screams out at dobby don't you ever dare
to steal the lives of innocent people
who had nothing to do with your downfall
he then continues by saying that if
dobby wants to take out his pain on
someone he should do it on them the
todorokis instead a fierce and
determined shot then launches his new
super move flash fire fist phosphorus
right at dobby and the sheer power and
heat of this attack looks like it's
about to disintegrate dobby's entire
body and that is how this chapter ends
with the battle to the death between two
overpowered brothers reaching its climax
and unfortunately we're gonna have to
wait quite a while to see how it all
turns out because mha is now going on a
multi-week break but even though the
break thing sucks this chapter was just
amazing the artwork portraying this
clash of two incredible burning fires
and burning desires was next level so
kudos to horikoshi and the entire mha
manga staff this battle could actually
be a way bigger moment in the story than
people realize and that's what i want to
talk about right now i mean of course
deku and shigaraki are the main stars of
this war arc and the final showdown will
go down between the two of them but we
also can't underestimate the importance
of this fight dobby may actually die
here the fact that he has gone berserk
and is scorching his own body just
because he wants to kill shoto is a
pretty massive death flag and i mean
throughout the story he has been
portrayed as a villain who can't be
redeemed he has no remorse for his
actions he is disturbed and obsessed
with revenge to the point that he
refuses to listen to reason and he just
continues to hurt more and more innocent
people without a second thought unless
something changes drastically dobby will
not give up his villain ways at any cost
and the only way to stop him will be to
kill him or to let him kill himself by
having his own flames consume him now we
are in the middle of a war arc and also
in the final act of the story so a major
villain like dobby dying at this point
wouldn't be a huge shock that said if
shoto really is the one who is forced to
literally kill his own brother it will
be a character defining moment for him
and for the entire story the ua students
have been through a lot that's for sure
but they haven't been in a situation
where they have to literally kill
someone and certainly not a member of
their own family shoto showed himself to
be both brave and noble when he agreed
to take responsibility for defeating
dobby but if this battle ends in dabi's
death then shoto will never be the same
again and neither will the story
personally i think that shotok killing
dobby or dobby dying in this fight as a
result of his own flames would be good
for the entire series i say that because
it would make the story feel darker and
more realistic
not every villain can be saved and if a
villain is out of control and determined
to keep hurting innocent people killing
him may be the only option and also a
necessity seeing shoto and the other
students having to come to terms with
this would add a new dimension to the
mha world and it would make everything
feel a lot more gritty and more real now
of course dobby could come back after
shoto's attack and kill shoto instead
but i don't see that happening shoto has
been through a lot to get here and he is
a fan favorite so if anyone dies in this
battle it will be dobby and if dobby
doesn't die and he ends up like atoning
for his sins somehow personally i think
that would be unrealistic given what we
know about his warped character but
we'll have to wait and see what do you
guys think did shoto just kill dabi or
will dabi survive this will shoto
eventually be forced to kill dobby or
will dabi kill shoto instead or do you
think that they could both survive this
fight definitely leave your thoughts
down in the comments below you know i
always love hearing from you if you're
interested in more mha content right now
check out my video on a potential mha
time skip link in the description don't
forget to leave a like to help out with
that youtube algorithm and of course if
you're not subscribed yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury he
is an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including alpha sigma pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamien water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the fallen
chosen spider-like tennelle tungsten
targets and baked buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh on
hell crews alicia octor bonnie parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit ollyvania and mando if you guys
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you